oh
no
no
that was true the time has finally come
i am super excited to put the 16 inch m1
max macbook pro against some serious
competition the razer blade 15 advanced
with an i9 a core processor the rtx 3080
with 16 gigabytes of video memory 32
gigs of ram and both having a one
terabyte ssd with a price difference of
only 100
and this is the razer with a 4k oled
display and we will see not only how
they compare in terms of the design the
speakers webcams these displays but also
performance in different benchmarks and
real-world tests such as photo editing
video editing blender 3d and more we're
also going to see something that most
people don't do and that is unplugged
performance for the times we're using
this actually as a laptop and you can't
plug into wall power let's start out
with the external differences the razer
is a 15-inch machine compared to a
16-inch macbook pro so as you guys could
see the footprint is a little bit larger
on the 16-inch but not by that much
surprisingly and even though the razor
looks thicker on the desk that's because
of its thicker feet so in reality
thickness is about the same and the
razor needs those feet because its
intake fans are on the bottom with these
cut outs and an exhaust at the top
instead of having the vents on the side
so they don't get blocked by blankets if
it's on your lap and the exhausts that
go up the screen as far as ports the
macbook finally caught up but the razer
still has an extra usb type a port there
on the right hand side now the hdmi on
the razer is 2.1 so supports 8k at 60hz
or 4k at 120 which is really nice and
the sd card is uhs type 3 instead of uhs
type 2 so it's twice the speed but of
course those cards don't exist yet now
the left side both have charging ports
apple's is magsafe which is nice both
have headphone jacks apples offers high
impedance support for those crazy
headphones we have thunderbolt 4 on both
but the macbook has two of those ports
with full bandwidth and the razer gives
us two more usb a ports also keep in
mind that with the razer you have to use
this dedicated charging adapter if you
want to get the proper performance
whereas the macbook even if you choose
to use usb type-c you'll get full
charging other than the fast charge to
50 opening these up one thing i love
about the razer it has windows hello so
already logged me in usually if it's
been sitting for a while it will dismiss
the lock screen automatically in this
case i just hit the space bar and on the
macbook we have touch id which is less
convenient now as far as the keyboards
and the track pads there is no doubt
that the macbook is better in each way
the keyboard feels nicer and the
trackpad is not the diving board design
that is uneven you have that nice force
touch that has really great gestures and
it just works super well now before we
compare oled to mini led let's compare
the speakers i'm excited now because
they have been updated here we have this
thx spatial logo compared to these apple
speakers which are known to be good so
let's go ahead and take a listen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right guys well that started off
pretty decent and then it got horrible
now the razer used to have super quiet
speakers it was insanely embarrassing
they made these a lot louder but there
is no beast it's almost like the woofers
got disconnected and then when the bass
drop hit the whole volume went down so
at first it was actually louder than the
macbook which was impressive but with no
bass but then it just dropped so i don't
really know how thx is putting their
logo on this because even though it's
loud it is not sound good and it's not
consistent as far as webcam quality
apple finally updated to 1080p cameras
with better lenses and they still have
the same studio quality mics as they
call them
advanced version of the razer blade also
comes with a 1080p camera so you guys
let me know which one looks better in
the good lighting scenario now since
most people don't use studio lights like
youtubers here is the macbook in a lower
light situation just like most people's
homes in the evenings and here's the
razer in a lower light scenario like
most people have at their homes so let
me know which one looked better and
which one sounded better down in the
comments section below and now let's get
into this place and we have a ton of
differences first off yes we have a
notch on the macbook it does stand out
not so much in this background but
definitely pops apple did give us a
little bit of extra space for the menu
bar when they added that notch they
didn't take it away now on the razor we
have that huge chin down below almost
like a mini imac
with that design now the aspect ratios
are different we have 16 by 10 plus the
extra space compared to 16x9 so this is
a much wider smaller display and then as
far as resolutions the razer is a little
bit higher we have a pure 4k display
compared to an almost 4k display with
the macbook now the mac also has a pro
motion
120 hertz display for that super smooth
animations and if you want to play games
at higher frequencies and it can also
drop all the way down to 24 hertz to
save you battery life if you're watching
movies or you can set select custom
resolutions if you're doing video
production both of these support dci p3
colors which is great for those that
work with colors and photo or video but
the razer is only an 8 bit display not a
10-bit and with that with these oled
displays you have to be extremely
careful because if you change brightness
the colors do shift so you need to
calibrate them yourself at the
brightness you're going to use it at and
stick to that brightness if you want
accurate colors as far as normal
brightness both are quite good the
macbook is a little bit brighter though
but the viewing angle difference is
dramatic the ola display on the razer it
keeps both its colors and its brightness
much better if you are viewing from the
side or from the top whereas the macbook
you need to be sitting directly in front
of it to get proper colors now aside
from brightness we have reflectivity and
apple has amazing coatings on here so
when you're outside with that brightness
you do not have any issues or in bright
rooms whereas the razer has one of the
most reflective screens that i've seen
i've reviewed this oled screen display
in their previous laptops it has not
changed is pretty much like a mirror now
this also matters when you are watching
hdr content but unfortunately i guess we
have to plug in the razer in order to
stream hdr and now all of a sudden i
don't know why but everything is super
laggy even though i did go into razer
synapse and i maxed out all the
performance to the boost setting the
highest one all right guys so i'm going
through all the hdr settings trying to
adjust everything and no matter what the
windows look weird
i tried chrome i tried edge the hdr is
looking horrific right now this those
performance issues i don't really know
what the deal is i mean look at that
i have not seen it this bad so um i
don't know what's going on everything's
blowing out of course the screen isn't
any brighter than about 450 nits so i
can't really get that peak maybe that's
why it's blowing stuff out so i'm just
gonna go ahead and disable that and then
we'll look at the content without all
those issues and wow okay now the
performance is back now we're getting
everything running smoothly again so now
playing these back we're getting hdr on
the macbook now this video here and
youtube's limited to about a thousand
nits but this display goes up to 1600
peak compared to about 450 and the crazy
thing is that even though the macbook is
not an oled display our blacks are
looking much deeper because of all the
reflectivity on this display with the
razer now in darker environments
reflectivity is less of an issue so that
definitely helps the razer but the
macbook still looks like as deeper
contrast maybe because of that layer of
touch screen on the razor and obviously
the highlights pop a lot more and we
have nicer colors as well now where the
oled display stands out is blooming
because the pixels are actually turned
off even in the craziest high contrast
situations like this you have no
blooming whereas on macbook you do see
blooming where you have full brightness
with those bright light bars white bars
and then pure darks right next to it and
of course the razer is a touchscreen
which is why it might be so reflective
so if you're somebody that likes to be
able to use your finger and scroll that
is definitely a benefit for you and now
getting into performance we are going to
start out by testing the ssds both of
these do have the same one terabyte we
know that the macbook has new faster
ssds but look at this in the same aja
disk speed test the razer actually beats
it by almost a thousand and read and a
few hundred in right now of course
blackmagic this speed test it actually
runs quite a bit faster also over 5000
in read but this is a fair test and now
for a real world test we have to
transfer our folder that has all our
test files so i'm gonna go ahead and
plug it in the razor has those fastest
as these so it shouldn't be an issue
because it has super fastness as these
and this thunderbolt drive reads at
about 2000 or so it's taking a little
bit to ramp up here that's interesting
our macbook finished in a minute and 53
seconds for this transfer and actually
the file size was slightly lower showing
up on windows compared to mac was 204
gigabytes compared to 220 but let's see
what happens alright finally it is
starting to kick up here it seems to not
want to go over about 900 megabytes
it'll write fast and slow down even
though that is a thunderbolt 4 port and
this is a thunderbolt drive alright so
that took five minutes and 51 seconds
compared to a minute and 53
i don't know what the deal is there i
looked over here it's connected as a pci
device so it is running with nvme not
usbc i read online some people posting
and people saying there's issues maybe
not of power going through i don't
really know maybe we should just get rid
of this test but i guess we'll just
leave it in and now let's get into the
cpu testing we're going to start out
with geekbench 5. both of these have as
you see we have 32 gigs of ram and they
have eight high performance cores of
course the m1 pro also has two
efficiency cores which makes up for just
a tiny bit of difference but the i9 can
scale to much higher frequencies and
both are plugged in what the heck vadim
why are we scoring so low is this normal
4 000 yeah 4 000
917 single core
okay
oh my goodness okay so looks like we're
unplugged go check the cab go check the
cable down there it's plugged in here
all the way yeah i mean it's like not
plugged in fully there you go now it's
fully played yep i see it wait how are
we at 30 battery life
we didn't even do any performance tests
yet other than this one run of geekbench
and then those other speaker tests and
display tests
um our macbook is at 89 we started both
of these at 100 battery and we're not
doing a battery life test because we
know this thing needs plug to be plugged
in um for at least the graphics testing
do you think that's why the ssd was
running so slow i don't know man
yep it's now breaking that 900 megabyte
per second barrier still only at 1.1 up
throttling a little bit the
the fans are running i don't know if
this is full blast you guys hear that
this is crazy so as soon as it goes
above 900 the fans kick up louder and
then it throttles down a little bit and
the fans cool down
all right but we are definitely getting
a lot better speeds now so it looks like
yes the ssd external ssd is throttled if
you're on battery power even though we
maxed out all the performance settings
for windows for the razer and bam we are
done that was faster
but the highest i ever saw hit is 1.4
gigahertz instead of 2 gigahertz or yeah
2 gigabytes a second it took 4 minutes
and 19 seconds with it plugged in
with all that fan noise so this kind of
just proves that this is like an
all-in-one mini desktop that you can
unplug and bring with you and then plug
back in now we will do a couple more
unplug tests just to see the performance
difference but man that just proves a
point especially that 30 battery life
after just i don't know an hour hour and
a half of us shooting compared to um
oh this is plugged in i think it was 88
or so all right we have our scores
plugged in and it looks like single core
the macbook is 11 faster and multi-core
it is 35 faster and taking a look at
that first unplug score we got the
single core is almost twice as fast and
the multi-core is almost three times
faster that's crazy maybe that's why
when i tried testing hdr everything got
super choppy and laggy that makes me
want to test our web browsing test
speedometer 2.0 so let's go ahead and
run that oh
no
no
that was true oh no you said 140 look at
this 86.97
thankfully when it's plugged in it
actually gets really excellent web
browsing performance 203.5 is quite high
the macbook's still about 34 faster but
that doesn't matter it's both quick but
when you unplug no wonder is running so
slow before this thing is limiting power
so much to save battery life that i
haven't seen a score this bad in such a
long time and it definitely is slow for
web browsing so even when you're wait
when you're web browsing make sure to
plug this machine in now i don't want to
come off seeing like some crazy person
disney on this laptop of course it needs
the power it has this 30 80 inside
that's what we are excited to test out
somewhere to run geekbench 5's compute
test using metal on the mac and cuda for
nvidia on the razer now with that this
is the most powerful slim laptop that
you can get today now we are super
excited to test out alder lake um those
laptops will be coming out hopefully
soon and we will get it as soon as we
possibly can so if you guys want to see
some comparisons with the macbook and
the new alder lake chips make sure you
guys are subscribed and with that you
guys can help us reach our goal of 1
million subscribers before the end of
the year we would absolutely appreciate
it all right guys finally we have a
great result look at that performance
with that 3080 with 16 gigabytes of
video memory almost 140 000 compared to
63
747.
that is a difference of more than double
now we did actually prove in our last
video that geekbench is not giving the
full performance of this m1 max chip it
only uses 36 watts instead of using up
to 46
but of course we will test out some more
real world tests now we also ran this on
battery power and we were surprised we
got a score of pretty much 82 000 so yes
you do lose quite a bit of performance
but it still is better than the macbook
pro and we'll see how that also affects
real world use and now see how the 3080
compares to the m1 max when we're doing
a gaming workload we have 3dmark's new
wildlife extreme we're going to run the
unlimited mode it's going to be off
screen so no difference in resolutions
and i want to see how much power both of
these gpus suck alright guys the score
is in and this is
crazy so as far as the frame rate our
macbook has a 121.4 fps of course that
was off screen or also be limited 120
with pro motion and the razer with the
30 80 got 129.12
that's only a difference of six percent
uh between frame rate that is insane and
that is because this test is optimized
for metal just like games for example
where the warcraft is now optimized it
will get basically the same frame rate
between a 3080 plugged in and the m1 max
with the 32 core graphics now if the
game is not optimized of course it is
going to run much worse and yes there
are way less games for mac windows is
the way to go for gaming but taking a
look at the gpu clock the frequencies
both ran at about 1.3 gigahertz which is
interesting but as far as the amount of
power needed to get this performance our
macbook only needed 43.3 watts to hit
that performance whereas the 3080 uses
up to 106
watts to get that same performance so
that is basically literally double the
wattage now i was also curious about the
graphics performance on battery when
we're maxing out the gpu just like when
you're gaming this test and when we did
that the razers 3080 dropped down to 780
megahertz and then the wattage dropped
from 106 down to 46 so pretty much
matching what our m1 max chip is yeah so
the m1 max didn't change at all they got
the same score but the razer went down
to from 129 fps to
79.58 whereas the max stayed the same at
121. so with pretty much the same power
usage the performance difference is
pretty massive with the macbook being 58
faster and now let's get into something
more serious we have blender opened up
right here we have a new sample project
from hishnash he created this for us
that is pretty intensive on memory so we
jumped up the different counts on here
let's go ahead and render this first one
all right we have our scores and this
task uses both the gpu and the cpu
and it looks like our macbook was able
to finish in 19.44 seconds compared to
30.24 with the razer that's a difference
about 55
and now let's run splashbox which you
can download on blender's website
yourself and test out your system this
one right here uses mostly cpu and bam
we are finished the mac did finish first
it took
21.62 seconds compared to 27.09 it's a
difference of 25 so less than what we
saw in geekbench but of course that
tests a wide variety of tests so looks
like for blender for cpu tests um the
performance isn't that huge of a
difference and now let's test party tug
which you can also download this one is
mostly
based i have the shaders compiled ahead
of time it took quite a bit longer with
the razer to do so and now we're gonna
go ahead and render this and wow that
was almost instant right there
super quick using graphics and this time
the razer one took 4.19 seconds compared
to 6.37 seconds so you got to wait a
couple extra seconds uh with the mac um
no excuses for the mac it definitely
lost by about 50 percent uh but we are
still using opengl i believe metal
support is going to be coming out next
year which will speed it up but for now
the 3080 definitely takes the win in
graphics rendering and now let's jump
into photo editing with lightroom as far
as the performance when you're actually
doing the editing there's no difference
both these are beasts of machines the
one difference you'll notice is just fan
noise with the razer constantly kicking
about the fans when the intel processor
has its turbo boost kicking in now one
thing i do want to test before we export
these 50 edited 42 megapixel raw images
is the enhanced so adobe super
resolution this is interesting we have
an estimate of 10 seconds for
the macbook in only three seconds
for the razer so i wonder if it's using
uh the cuda in order to do that let's go
ahead and hit enhance oh yeah it
definitely was using the graphics there
like 14 gigs of graphics memory
so the speed differences though we have
11.6 seconds for the razer and 18.2 for
the macbook that is 56 faster pretty
much what we saw in blender when we did
that last export using graphics and now
let's export all 50 of those raw edited
images to jpeg and let's hit start and
the first thing i noticed is that these
cores when plugged in hit a hundred
degrees celsius three of them and the
fans are just ramping up we saw 85 watts
on the cpu compared to the mac which
only hits 30 watts on the cpu and bam
the razer thermal throttled down the
wattage is now 50 the clock speeds about
3.2 which is similar to the max so it
can't really sustain a heavy turbo for
long i mean that is a lot of power and
of course a lot of fan noise to get rid
of that heat whereas the max fans at the
end of this export just turned on and
they're literally running at idle and
that's a great thing with these 16 inch
macbook pros bam the mac is done here
we're starting to get maybe a little bit
more performance now as the fans creak
up again and bam we are finished with
the razer it took a minute and 54
seconds which is an excellent time at
least when it's plugged in here uh
previous max they would take a lot
longer with the intel processors they
wouldn't ramp up as high on the fans or
the wattage so this thing is fast but
the new 16 inch with the m1 max chip the
10 core processor we're looking at a
minute and 21
really really fast exporting speeds and
of course it doesn't slow down if it's
on battery and now we're running on
battery power at 99 but unplugged and
the razer is silent so if you want it to
run really cool really quiet because
that helps a lot and as you see
it's only running at 60 to 63 degrees
celsius so very cool that's because it's
only using about 20 watts of power and
running the fastest at 1.6 gigahertz now
it's running at like 1.3 it's definitely
taking longer though and that took three
minutes and 24 seconds on battery power
and now let's get into video editing i
have davinci resolve opened up on both
which is really well optimized for both
systems better than premiere of course
we can't use final cut in this
comparison and here i have a standard
project open it is h.265
why is that stunning a little bit all
right there you go it's good h.265 both
these handle it without any issue they
both have really good decoders and
encoders nvidia is actually killer for
that so as far as projects for most
people hr 265 like this or h264 with a
couple let's apply a little bit of
correction some film grain both laptops
will do a killer job now i'm going to go
ahead and export this project here and
then we'll get into some tougher tests
and bam let's render this five minute
project right out of the gate both are
flying it looks like the razer is going
at about 65 frames per second which is
almost not triple but a lot higher than
the actual project and on the macbook
we're looking at 89 90 fps
right around there
apple did update with dual encoders in
the past this razer smoked the i9 intel
16 inch macbook pro absolutely
demolished it exporting h.265 which is a
bit faster than h.264 all right we have
our scores the razor was extremely fast
a minute and 48 seconds but the macbook
did a task in a minute and 22 seconds
almost four times faster than real time
whereas the razer was about 2.75 times
faster than the real time definitely
incredible performance on both now i
don't want to do unplugged performance
because we've done it too many times but
we've tested this in the past and it is
about three times slower than this
result once you unplug it slows down
quite a bit but pretty crazy performance
here now the next thing i'm going to do
is stabilize the 20 second 4k clip this
is going to use 100 gpu power and help
us compare the gpu capabilities in
davinci resolve both of these are flying
this is gonna be a very close one okay
wow wow the razor took just 10 seconds
i've never seen a laptop go that fast
incredible it's the first time i'm
actually testing it after all these
tests that we've done this last week and
the mac with 32 cores m1 max chip took 9
seconds so that is what 10 faster in
davinci resolve running metal versus
cuda that is crazy crazy fast on both
and to push his gpus even more which i
mean they were maxed out anyways but we
are gonna do some noise reduction
testing i have black magic raw footage
this is 4k and then i have
three frames of temporal noise reduction
i also have spatial noise reduction same
exact file same settings on both and
this is gonna have to use the graphics
i'm in the color tab to see the accurate
frames per second let's hit play and
look at that guys the razer is giving us
a solid 17 frames per second out of the
24 total while the macbook is only
giving us 10 or 11 frames per second
definitely worst performance for noise
reduction and davinci resolve and
continuing with black magic raw this is
a 6k project that is color graded
running on both of course
the macbook doesn't have decoders for
this kind of footage i don't think the
razer does either they just accelerated
with the graphics both are playing back
perfectly smoothly handling this without
an issue i'd like to export this five
minute project to pro res but i can't of
course with windows so let's go ahead
and export to h.264 all right guys i was
not expecting this
uh i thought that the macro would slow
down because there's less graphics power
and then the rtx laptop would speed up
but here it is actually going faster
than with h.265 even though it doesn't
have decoders for blackmagic raw it was
going at like 96 frames per second
compared to 55 for the razer and the
fans didn't even turn on for the five
minute export on the macbook compared to
full speed pretty much the whole time
with the razer that is crazy and as far
as the results the razer was slower this
time than with h.264 two minutes and 11
seconds meaning it was limited by the
graphics performance but the macbook was
faster a minute and 15 seconds
which means that maybe b4 is limited by
decoder since blackmagic raw does not
use those that is insane usually we do
less graphics testing and video editing
than this but i keep trying to throw
more workloads on it to give razer
something to work with for that higher
power graphics card so what else can we
throw at it i can't do canon r5 footage
because this thing runs it slow it can't
decode that well so the mac would win
there um i probably can't do prores
stuff because of the encoding and plus
the macbook has dedicated decoders as
well for it so it would make it much
faster i guess let's maybe throw some
red footage on there that's gonna have
to use all graphics maybe it'll just go
all the way to 8k all right this is an
8k project in an ak timeline with good
debating and with color grading
and it looks like in the color tab
because it doesn't play back perfectly
we're getting about 15 frames per second
on the razor 15 sometimes 16 and we're
getting 19 and 20 frames per second
on the macbook that
okay this is just interesting i was not
expecting that either and the mac
it's silent and the razor
well you guys might be able to hear that
for yourselves oh my goodness this is
even worse when we're exporting this it
looks like the difference is the same or
maybe even a little bit greater with the
macbook exporting at 18 and a half 18 18
and a half frames per second 19 and a
half compared to 14 and a half here with
the razer and we're not limited by our
encoders we're not limited by
you know video memory this thing has 16
gigabytes of video memory here of course
the mac uh this thing has 32 but it's a
share with the cpu and the gpu
it's mostly just the raw graphics
performance and we are plugged in
batteries maxed out and it's handling
the red footage
better on the mac as well all right guys
the export is done and this was not a
five minute project it was only a one
minute ak project to h.265
so no limitations on encoders on either
system just raw graphics here and uh the
razer took a minute and 41 seconds which
is still good but the macbook took a
minute and 19 seconds
so there you go and just to be honest
with you guys you guys maybe heard my
tone of my voice changed the tone of it
um i just was not expecting these
results uh going into this i mean i knew
the battery life's gonna be way better
we weren't even able to test it because
i also knew that the performance of
these rtx cards dropped dramatically uh
when you're unplugging now i didn't
expect the cpu to drop as dramatically
as it did
um you know speaker screen all of that
stuff we've tested these screens before
but man at least in the video editing
with the rtx graphics card and
especially stuff that's not being using
you're not using the decoders like black
magic raw and the red
i thought it was going to just
absolutely smoke this 32 core
macbook you know the price difference is
almost the same 100 bucks more for the
mac uh you get the much nicer display
crazy much better battery life and all
these tests would be the same on battery
better speakers and you guys saw that
performance as well now the razer yes
for gaming
even though if it both are optimized
it's similar of course this is what you
want for windows games so much more
games everything runs without any issues
as long as you're plugged in no problems
and we did see in blender some faster
speeds um and then as far as uh noise
reduction in real time we had 17 fps
compared to 11
but overall
i just was not expecting the macbook to
hold up so well compared to this rtx
3080. but you guys give let me know your
your comments your thoughts down in the
comment section below i'd love to hear
him if you guys aren't yet subscribed
and you want to see us compare this
macbook to the new alder lake laptops
once those come out click that circle
above to subscribe you guys can help us
reach 1 million subscribers check out
our merch down below check out one of
those great videos right over there this
has been max and i'll see you in the
next video
[Music]